all rise where I've talked about the top
10 best movies of 2018 now it's time to
talk about the top 10 worst movies to
2018 as before with my best list and as
always I haven't seen every movie that
came out this year it would just be
exhausting but there are a lot of [ __ ]
movies I just skipped out on it's like
life's too short I'd rather be doing
something else and I'm pretty sure 2018
has given me or will give me more
chances a lot of [ __ ] movies that came
out in 2018 I swear I could have made a
top 15 list and also keep in mind when I
list the movies off I'm not gonna give
reviews of the movies brief synopsis as
to what I thought about them but the
reviews can be found here on YouTube
I've reviewed them all you can go check
them out and keep in mind as my opinion
is not written in stone you're gonna
have a differing opinion in mind blah
blah blah we know how opinions work so
keep that in mind if there's a movie you
think should be on here that's not on
here what do you think about this year
there were a bunch of bad movies but
usually I have a lot of movies I just
hate it's clear it's like yeah these are
the ones that are on the top 10 worst
few movies on this list that I'm like
yes from the get-go totally gonna be on
the list there were a lot of movies
though I was like I don't even hate them
I just kind of I don't like them
or they're bad but there's kind of
forgettable but they made the list
because there were a lot of those enough
of the terrible of the forgettable let's
talk about ten of them here
no but a starting off at number 10 is
movie I didn't think was going to be on
my top 10 worst list of 2018 solo a Star
Wars story I know did a fun thing with
my spoiler video I wasn't trying to ride
the line was trying to make a point
other point being I just I don't like
this movie and I've met people who are
like if you don't see it as a Star Wars
movie as a space smuggler movie it's
pretty fun I disagree I think it's a
space smuggler movie it sucks I think
there's a Star Wars movie it sucks just
look at the character of Han Solo his
arc in this movie is exactly the same as
his arc and a new hope a smuggler with a
heart of gold trying to pass himself off
as no I don't have a heart of gold I'm
hardcore and by the Andy shows he has a
heart of gold by helping the rebellion
same thing so other than that redundancy
the entire movie has a messy-ass plot so
they rely on hey Easter eggs remember I
remember to carry the movie I would say
I don't blame the movie for having a
messy-ass plot because I had two
different directors if I didn't blame
the studio for doing that [ __ ] soul of a
star war story it's the movie that just
changed my perspective on all of it I
was there going Disney star wars yeah
geez he's gonna bring it back and there
were some a beanies or a sanae sayers on
line or like now they're gonna [ __ ] it
into the dirt and I was like shame on
you no they're not Oh yep maybe their
babies could background noise I don't
know all I know is it changed my
perspective a movie that does that's
either great or horrible and it's not
right so here we are nine next up we
have Pacific Rim up riser Pacific Rim
uprising was such a disappointment
especially because Pacific Rim is so rad
it was such a surprise this movie like
any of the fun the original Pacific Rim
had an throwdown was okay I didn't hate
everything leading up to that generally
hate it but even the best of the
fighting in this movie showed that it
lacked with Guillermo del Toro brought
to the original movie and there's this
weird plot twist device with Charlie Day
oh man I was out at that point no no
more go join Independence Day resurgence
on the not my blu-ray shelf next up we
have Winchester again with the movie
with an interesting concept that the
payoff was [ __ ] totally was it [ __ ] in
this movie it was boring this movie
tried to be a horror movie with Bryn's
even have people good acting chops
behind it they couldn't save this it's
as simple as predictable as scares with
pacing that went on to a crawl movies
like ambien the horror movie like to see
a documentary about the Winchester
mansion that'd be cool don't want to see
this movie again it's just a fact next
up we have a wrinkle in time this one we
had a great trailer I'll say that the
movie itself didn't have great anything
this movie is a boring bland forgettable
colorful roadtrip movie by road trip I
mean they're going to different worlds
but they're stopping off going this is
nice let's go to the next one and the
movie was completely messy the movies
completely sloppy and I had a point in
the third act the acting man like I said
in my review we're dealing with child
actors I don't want to be too harsh here
but there's no one give a [ __ ] where
there are no auditions like everybody
behind this movie was like we care so
much about this movie but none of that
care came across on screen just came
across as a really rushed hallmark movie
with a bigger budget for six
I'll give Cloverfield paradox this
brilliant marketing strategy the only
marketing this movie had was a Super
Bowl ad you're gonna reach a lot of
people that way and you release it that
night that was actually really neat I
hadn't seen anything like that but I
watched it that night and I was like
maybe this is flies only movies that'll
make a gamble like that
our movies that have nothing to lose
much like how solo a Star Wars story
killed my perception as to where Star
Wars could be going Cloverfield paradox
killed my perception of what the
Cloverfield name-brand was a Cloverfield
movies our movies that don't get a lot
of traction but Studios need people to
watch them of course
so they stamped the name Cloverfield
under the title and maybe
people watch this movie actually does
tie in to Cloverfield by the end but
everything that ties in to Cloverfield
just felt like an afterthought it's like
the people who made this movie thought
weird [ __ ] happening equals good sci-fi
and that is just not the case I walked
out going that's what people mean when
they say they don't like sci-fi what
they mean is I don't like bad sci-fi
like Cloverfield paradox fine next up is
the nun the nun is just stupid which is
funny because the nun characters kind of
become some weird icon in modern day
horror like I don't think my dad will
know what it is but most people who
watch movies definitely horror movies
know what the nun is so this is the nun
origin story again it's like they're
like that'll work that'll be enough and
it's just not enough it's another movie
that's relying on the fact that this is
going to tie in to a franchise that
people liked oh there are references and
easter eggs that you might notice it's
like Where's Waldo Where's Waldo doesn't
have a good plot it's just finding
things you ever find Waldo shoe in a
Where's Waldo book can be like great
second act of that story the
foreshadowing was blatantly obvious and
the jump scares were abundant like I
said in my review I think this is the
best way I can phrase it so I'm gonna
say it again here everything you've seen
done in the none was done better and
other horror movies before next up we
have action point the only thing worse
than bad horror is bad comedy or they're
at least on par action point was Johnny
Knoxville doing his jackass stunts my
stunts I mean really just falling off
[ __ ] and hurting himself but now it's in
a narrative it's in the plot it's in a
movie not hidden cameras pranking people
or anything like that I guess it's a
true story and that's what makes us all
the more tragic this is a true story
it's probably interesting with a better
screenwriter a better script as it
stands is Johnny Knoxville hanging out
with Chris Pontius in a bad movie movies
about a cricket es rust bucket theme
park in a disaster of a person who wants
to save it with a lot of falling pain
disaster I should have had a blast but
as Chuck on my watch I just wanted the
pain to end I would have rather gone to
the [ __ ] doctor next up we have Fifty
Shades freed this probably could be
number one in fact three two and one
could all be number one I want to give
this number one I don't want this to get
a gold medal for anything even for being
bad I needed to settle for the bronze I
want it to be so bad when people list
off these are the number one shitty
movies that Jeremy's ever done
past ten years I don't want this to be a
part of the conversation but I'm happy
it's over now I'm happy I don't have to
watch any more of these [ __ ] things
this wasn't as bad as the second one
there is that but still it suffers from
the same [ __ ] this feels like Twilight
fan fiction because it is in fact
Twilight fan fiction you're not buying
these to get out of town who's rooting
for them it's over now so that's good
next the strangers pray at night
remember what I was saying about bad
horror which is a bummer because the
original strangers was actually pretty
cool but this movie everyone's stupid
from the get-go you're like things are
getting weird and shady just leave this
place is there a video on the internet
right now like how the strangest prey at
night should have ended where they just
show up they're like nope they get back
in their cars and just drive off the end
that could totally happen in this movie
and it should have happened in this
movie was this one of this January
movies I forget when this movie even
came out and feels like a January movie
classic sequel itis first one was neat
so we got to make a sequel and it just
really kind of betrays everything the
first one did so here it is number one
this is the number one movie this is the
movie I walked out of a little earlier
than it ended admittedly that's
Nutcracker in the far realms when it
racked up like she gets back I was like
okay gonna beat traffic let's go so I
don't actually know what happened at the
very very very end of this movie I'm
also really confident nothing happened
that brought this movie out of the grave
for me I didn't like anything about this
everything about it was just bad like
the main girl so I think she has a
bright future maybe one day she can be
the next Helen Mirren who'll be in a
shitty disaster like this and Nutcracker
the title character completely
forgettable Keira Knightley what voice
is that what was she doing it came
across as 99-cent Narnia those Narnia
movies stopped happening why would you
take a franchise that stopped happening
as your inspiration don't know of the
day but it really looks like they did I
get the big thing right now is to go
into new directions with pre-existing
properties or plays or musicals but if
you're gonna go in a new direction at
least have a concept that this new
direction is gonna be good
all I refuse to believe in the pitch
room they were like this is gonna be
better than a nutcracker movie that
actually follows Nutcracker that we
might be able to actually do I don't
know I hated this movie and it's such an
anticlimactic
ending to the
video it's nothing huge nothing bold
nothing crazy it's just Nutcracker in
the four realms oh that's the worst okay
bye yes best I got it's just the movie I
hated most this year in any case that's
the tip of the pyramid the top tier
[ __ ] of 2018 but I hope you all had a
great year like this is the final video
of 2018 2018 so weird [ __ ] year just
was wasn't it just kind of crazy and I
hope you had a good Christmas or
Hanukkah or dick in a box whatever
you're celebrating and I hope you have a
very happy and safe new year most
importantly thank you for another year
of coming to my channel hanging out with
me digitally of course they listen to me
prattle on and Yammer on about movies
and things I like just thanks for a fun
year looking forward to 2019 and of
course I'm looking forward to reading
your top ten list of the top 10 worst
movies 2018 for you so whatever they are
whatever you think comment below let me
know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
[Music]